We got a pair of teens on TikTok who are going viral
for this interesting spring break story.
I'm dying to know what you think about this.
Oh, I'm so into this story.
(Ross laughs)
"New York Post" reports, Lydia and Jaeden went
on an all-inclusive vacation to Dominican Republic.
It sounds fun, right?
But they did this a month after they broke up.
(Drew laughs)
They said they were forced into it
when they found out the trip was non-refundable.
They booked it before they broke up.
Then Lydia tried to get it transferred to her mom,
but when she contacted the travel service,
they said, "Yeah, no, we don't do that."
So they TikTok'ed their entire trip.
(audience laughs)
Including the part where the hotel gave them a room
with just one bed in it.
(audience laughs)
Okay.
How bad do you need a vacation
if you're willing to go on with an ex?
(audience laughs)
I mean, this actually makes total sense to me.
They could not get a refund.
Uh-huh.
And I actually think they totally did the right thing
by going on it.
People do not have money to waste.
I just think this couple is cute,
and I love that they posted about this,
and I feel like people can relate to it.
And it's just like, oh, you know what?
Put all your baggage not on the plane
or even in the overhead.
Just don't bring it with you.
Yeah.
Just go on the trip and have fun.
And maybe... (laughs)
Maybe.
You know?
Maybe things might become illuminated.
But at least you're leaving the vacation
not having wasted money.
And I just have to say,
I think Nancy Meyers just found her first movie,
you're welcome, right here.
(audience laughs)
(audience applauds)
100%.
I'd watch it.
Okay, next up, we've got another teenager making bold moves.
This story comes from "The Week."
Chloe Campbell started working at The Coffee Pot,
her local coffee shop in Dufftown, Scotland
when she was just 15.
And now, four years later, she bought the place.
Hey,
(audience applauds)
Chloe.
That's right.
Chloe says her parents taught her to save money.
So she saved and saved and saved.
Every check she made, she saved.
And then she mentioned to the owner that she was thinking
about running her own place one day.
And then the owner said, "Buy this one," and she did.
Wow.
Congratulations, Chloe.
She's 19
(audience applauds)
and owns her own business.
That's amazing.
Amazing.
15, she started working there?
When I was 15, I worked at McDonald's,
and then I worked there for four years,
and you know-
You were the triple threat.
I was a triple threat, register, drive-through, and grill.
And all I ever got
(audience laughs)
was transferred to the McDonald's Express in the mall,
which was like...
(audience laughs)
You know what I mean?
How did was that feel?
It wasn't great. It wasn't great.
(audience laughs)
And it's all 'cause Steve, the manager...
And Steve, take the cake.
You know who you are, Steve.
(Drew and audience laughing)
You know who you are, and you didn't like me.
Well, what's up, Steve?
(audience laughs)
(audience applauds)
I worked in a coffee house, too, when I was 14.
And my boss, Robert, he used to come in with his cigarette.
"Lambchop, listen, darling.
(Ross and audience laughing)
the delivery for the muffins comes at 6:00 a.m., honey,
not 6:00 p.m.
You're driving me crazy,
and I can't fire you 'cause I don't have the heart."
Oh.
You know?
I love Robert.
Right, "Lambchop."
And then that is actually, fun facts, where I met my sister
and best friend, Cameron Diaz.
I was 14.
(Ross gasps)
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
At that coffee shop?
At that coffee shop.
She was a junior model. She was 16.
I was 14 and a barista, and we made friends,
and the story never ends, and-
Ah.
We're still family, so you know, "Lambchop."
Yeah.
"You're killing me, darling."
(Drew laughs)
(audience applauds)
Oh, I hope...
So congratulations, Chloe.
It looks like we're all doing all right.
(upbeat pop music)